Aqua Regia, Royal Water, is a mixture of two
acids,
hydrochloric acid and nitric acid. The reason
it’s called
‘royal water’ is because it dissolves
gold. Gold has
fascinated people for thousands of years because
it
doesn’t dissolve in anything, doesn’t
tarnish, always
looks nice and shiny, and this was a material
that could
dissolve it. So it was really something, the
lion of the
acids, like the lion of an animal, king of
the animals!
So Aqua Regia is a mixture of hydrochloric
acid and
nitric acid, but each of those is a mixture
of something
in water, a solution of something in water.
So
hydrochloric acid is hydrogen chloride, which
is an atom
of chlorine bonded to an atom of hydrogen,
now the
importance of this is that when the HCl dissolves
in
water the bond between them breaks and you
get
chloride ions, Cl-, and H+, hydrogen ions,
and it is the
formation of hydrogen ions which makes something
an
acid. So when you have the mixture of all
these ions you
get quite a soup. Now the exciting thing about
Aqua
Regia is that neither of the two acids by
themselves can
dissolve gold. Nitric acid doesn’t really
react with gold
very much at all, and HCl, hydrogen chloric
acid can’t
get a hold of the gold to get the reaction
going. But if
you can gold into solution then it can react.
So what
happens is as follows: the nitric acid can
attack the gold
and a very small proportion of the gold, relatively
few
atoms, are persuaded into going into solution
and there
is an equilibrium, some are coming off and
an equal
number are going back on to the surface. So
if you just
have the gold in there it appears to be unaffected.
If you
were on an atomic scale you would see atoms
coming
off and others going back, but nothing changes.
But
when you have the hydrogen chloride there,
the chloride
ions can attack the gold and turn them into
a different
compound so they can’t go back. So more
and more and
more gold atoms come off, until eventually
all of it is
converted to another acid, which is an acid
of gold with
four chlorine atoms around it. This material
is then quite
soluble in water, so provided you don’t
have too much
gold it will all dissolve. And once you have
the solution,
you will get a brownish solution or greenish
solution
depending how much gold is in there.
I’ve never seen Aqua Regia because it’s
quite a nasty
material, you have to use it in the fume cupboard,
because otherwise, because of these fumes
of NO2 and
unless you want to dissolve gold, you don’t
usually need
this. It is a pretty good cleaning material
if you have
glassware, beakers things like that that you
can’t clean
any other way. The sort of last resort is
‘we’ll try Aqua
Regia to see if that’ll do it?’ you know
really bang the
dirt. And it sometimes works, not always,
depends what
the dirt is.
Aqua Regia is Latin, for Aqua is the Latin
for ‘water’ as
in ‘aqueduct’ and also we use it in English
and the word
‘aqueous’ and things like that. There
is…and Regia is the
Latin for ‘royal’ as in ‘regal’, and
comes from the word
Rex which means the word ‘king’ in Latin.
Well there is quite a famous story about Aqua
Regia and
the institute of Niels Bohr, the Nobel Prize
winner, who
had an institute in Copenhagen and at the
beginning of
the Second World War when Denmark was still
neutral,
two German Nobel Prize winners, Max von Laue
and
Frank who had won the Nobel Prize before the
Second
World War sent their gold medals for safe-keeping
to
Denmark and someone in the lab at, in Denmark,
dissolved them in Aqua Regia and just put
the bottle on
the shelf where there were lots of other bottles
of
chemicals and they stayed there the whole
war because
nobody realised that they were gold and after
the war
the gold was recovered, the medals were re-struck
and
given back to the Nobel Prize winners.